- We're asked, "Which of
the following vectors have
"the same x component as vector a?"
And they tell us to
"Select all that apply"
This is vector a right over here
and we only have to concern
ourselves with the x component.
That's what they're asking us about.
Let's think about what
it's x component is.
We're starting at this
point right over here,
which has an x value of negative two and
we're going from x equals negative two
to x is equal to negative five.
Our change in x, another
way to think about it,
our x component.
We're going from negative
two to negative five.
Our x value goes down by three.
Our change in x is
equal to negative three.
That would also be the
x component of vector a.
We could say that vector a is equal to,
it's x component is negative three.
We're not concerning
ourselves with our y component
but we see that our y goes up by one.
So it's negative three comma one
but we just care about our x component.
Let's think about what other vectors here
have an x component of negative three.
That, if we start at our initial point
and go to the terminal point,
our x value has gone down by three.
We're gonna start with vector b here.
And let's see, if we start there
our x value is three at our initial point,
our starting point for that vector.
Then, to go to the x value
of the terminal point
we once again went down by three.
This has the same x component.
Vector b is going to be
negative three comma something.
I will select that one.
Let's think about vector c.
Vector c starts here
at x equals negative 4
and then it ends at x equals negative one.
It's x component is going to look,
one way to think about it, our change
in x is going to look like this.
You might be tempted to
say this is the same thing.
It has a length of three but notice,
we're not going three to the left,
the way that we did in
vector a or in vector b.
We're going three to the right.
Here our change in x is positive three
and so vector c is going to be
positive three comma something.
It's not gonna be vector c.
Now let's look at vector d.
Vector d starts over here, it's x value is
negative six and we're going from
x equals negative six to
x equals negative nine.
Once again we have gone down.
Our change in x is negative three.
That has the same x component.
If I were to say vector d
I would say it's negative
three comma something.
I haven't figured out what these are
but I don't need to for this problem.
So vector d also has the same x component,
an x component of negative
three and we're done.